Welcome to the show.
Yesterday was day three out of four of the
Republican National Convention.
We're going to look at pictures.
We're going to look at clips.
I'm going to give you sort of my thoughts
on how I would characterize the themes of
days one, two and three so far and will predict
the final night tonight.
But I have to say, and I think some other
people in the audience are feeling this way
as well, especially people who have been with
me on the live streams nightly.
I'm exhausted from this nonsense.
And yet the DNC last week was sort of tiring
because, you know, I tend to start work on
each day's show relatively early in the morning.
And so when it's nine to 11 p.m. and sometimes
it goes 10 minutes late and then people want
me to keep talking about what we saw there
just along days.
So that's that's like the normal tiredness.
But the RNC in particular is emotionally exhausting
because it's just constant lies and delusions
and depravity and diabolical claims and so
on and so forth.
So I'm very much looking for it to be over.
And I think our vacation in a couple of weeks
is going to be a much needed one.
But let's look at what happened yesterday.
So the keynote yesterday was Vice President
Mike Pence.
And there was a big build up to Mike Pence.
Karen Pence, his wife spoke earlier and they
had a big crowd.
And incredibly, if you didn't know a pandemic
was going on, you certainly wouldn't have
noticed it from watching the speech.
We have a few different pictures.
You'll see Mike Pence after the speech kind
of walking down and a fist bumping and high
flying people.
Nobody's wearing a mask.
Everybody on top of each other from news reports.
Nobody who was there was tested for coronavirus.
Donald Trump himself also because he just
can't stay away from any day of this convention,
showed up and came out at Fort McHenry in
Baltimore, Maryland, after Mike Pence his
speech.
And he was right up near people and again,
you know, were outdoors.
The transmission pop possibility is lower,
but you're talking about hundreds of people
here.
And then, of course, mathematically, you start
to it becomes more and more likely that somebody
is going to get the virus if they're hanging
around each other.
Donald Trump, they're right up on people.
And then, as you can see, just not a mask
in sight.
And maybe somebody was wearing a mask.
But from all the different angles, all the
different video and pictures that we have
of the event, it did not appear as though
anybody, anybody was wearing a mask.
People were sitting relatively close together.
It was like there was no pandemic going on.
So I tweeted yesterday, how many cases do
you think this event will be ultimately responsible
for?
Most people thought the number was certainly
more than zero, but it remains to be seen.
And again, it's the optics.
It's the optics of pretending and acting like
everything is normal.
Now, in terms of the themes of the three Republican
National Convention days so far, day one,
here's the way I see it.
Day one was unhinged, screaming, right.
Like upper screaming, outrageous, sort of
like amphetamine day where you had Don Junior
out of control, sweat eyes almost completely
swollen shut.
We'll talk about that later.
He's denied that the entire thing was fueled
by cocaine.
You had done Junior's girlfriend, Kimberly
Guilfoyle, reminiscent of North Korean propaganda,
screaming speech day two.
I would kind of call Downer Day, where it
was really a very boring down day capped by
Melania Trump's very low key, almost unenthusiastic
support of Donald Trump.
And indeed, if you've been following what's
been going on with the two of them for the
last four years, she may not be enthusiastic
about Donald Trump getting reelected.
And then day three last night.
I think was the dangerous day where you're
going to see the types of claims that were
made not just by Mike Pence but by other speakers
were the types of claims that could certainly
move people to real world violence.
So let's look at a cute couple of different
things.
One cutesy little idea that has been now it's
just become popular as a trope and during
the RNC is claiming Joe Biden and Democrats
are going to cancel and end stuff.
Remember, they're going to end the suburbs
was a popular one.
Here is Senator Joni Ernst, who is potentially
going to be removed from the Senate.
We can hope saying that if you elect Joe Biden,
he's going to ban animal agriculture and he's
also going to eliminate gas powered vehicles.
If given power, they would essentially ban
animal agriculture and eliminate gas powered
cars.
Now, of course, this is not true.
The truth is that Joe Biden does have Noam
Chomsky agrees.
I've looked at it and I don't know how anyone
could come to any other conclusion.
Joe Biden does have the most progressive climate
platform of any would be president.
If Joe Biden is elected, that will be the
most progressive climate platform.
And yes, it has aggressive goals for phasing
out the internal combustion engine, which
I am in favor of.
It has aggressive goals for reducing emissions
from animal agalloch agriculture.
But cows aren't going to be banned.
Steaks aren't going to be banned.
And at no time anytime soon are gas powered
vehicles going to be banned.
Another speaker going from Senator Joni Ernst
to a Senator Marsha Blackburn from Tennessee,
who is a longtime Republican bomb thrower.
She suggests that what Democrats want to do
is to keep Corona virus.
Lockdown's going so long that it will force
people into a dependency on the government.
I guess she imagines if you keep people locked
up, eventually they'll need the government
to bring them food.
They'll need the government to bring the medicine,
whatever the case may be, a crazy sort, sort
sort of exaggeration of what small government
people claim the left wants to do.
But she said it.
Hey, look, if the Democrats had their way,
they would keep you locked in your house until
you become dependent on the government.
Then we also heard as the nepotism continued
from Eric Trump's wife, Larra Trump, and one
of the funniest themes from her speech and
from others, like former football player Bill
Gesso ends and some others was the idea that
the Democratic Party are leftist coastal elites
when the entire Trump family and most of their
spouses are actually these coastal elites
that they decry?
Here is Larra Trump talking about when she
met the Trump family, saying they are hard
workers and really down to earth.
Any of those words never fully weighed on
me until I met my husband and the Trump family.
Any preconceived notion I had of this family
disappeared immediately.
They were warm and caring.
They were hard workers and they were down
to earth.
They reminded me of my own family.
They made me feel like I was home walking
the halls of the Trump Organization.
I saw the same family environment.
I also saw the countless women executives
who thrived there year after year.
Sort of like opposite day, like that.
That is the exact opposite of what the Trump
family is.
They brought in former football coach Lou
Holtz, who claims that Joe Biden isn't really
religious.
And this is actually really interesting.
So let's take a look at the clip.
The Biden ticket is a most radically pro-abortion
campaign in history.
They and other politicians are Catholic in
name only and abandoned innocent lives.
So I've been talking about this a lot lately,
including during the streams, because Joe
Biden is the religious candidate.
Now, I don't care about a candidate's religion.
I want religion completely separate from governance.
I don't believe in individual's religion should
play any kind of role in what the law should
be, et cetera.
Secularism doesn't mean people can't be religious
in their private lives as a matter of pride
of their own, you know, personal conviction.
But it should play no role in governance.
Donald Trump is probably not religious at
all.
Donald Trump is probably one of the least
religious presidents we've ever had.
Doesn't make him a good president.
I don't care.
Biden's the religious guy.
I'm not religious.
I prefer Biden because he'd be a better president.
But now they are going further because nominally,
everybody knows Joe Biden is a Catholic.
They now have to step it up and say Joe Biden
only claims to be a Catholic.
He's not really religious, which is the exact
type of mind reading that when we say that
person seems racist based on their actions.
The right says you don't know what's really
in their mind.
This is exactly the type of argument they're
making to claim, of course, without evidence
that Trump is the religious.
Candidate and Biden, it really is not because
he's lying about his Catholic faith.
Notice that it's an argument.
They have said is a bad argument when it comes
to racist beliefs with religious beliefs.
They're comfortable saying Biden's not actually
the religious guy, again, bringing up this
idea of law and order and how Trump will stop
chaos in the streets.
Take a look at that.
Last week, Joe Biden didn't say one word about
the violence and chaos engulfing cities across
this country.
So let me be clear.
The violence must stop, whether in Minneapolis,
Portland or Kenosha.
Too many heroes have died defending our freedom
to see Americans strike each other down.
We will have law and order on the streets
of this country for every American of every
race and creed and color.
Now, what is dangerous about this is that
they are pointing to chaos in the streets
now.
Now, again, protests have mostly been peaceful.
Most of the people who have actually committed
violence are art, don't actually appear to
be protesters.
They appear to be other things.
We're going to talk, of course, about Kyle
Rittenhouse momentarily.
But it's a very strange argument to make that
things are crazy in the streets right now
after Trump's been president for four years.
So you should reelect Donald Trump so he can
stop the craziness in the streets.
That doesn't really that doesn't make any
sense, but it doesn't matter to them.
And that's what's so dangerous about this
on Corona virus.
Mike Pence talking about how the on Corona
virus, we are actually a country of miracles,
and it's not unreasonable to expect a miracle
to help us with corona virus, which is just
unbelievably wild.
Listen to Mike Pence.
Say it here.
Now, last week, Joe Biden said that no miracle
is coming.
Well, Joe doesn't seem to understand is that
America is a nation of miracles.
And I'm proud to report that we're on track
to have the world's first safe, effective
corona virus vaccine by the end of this year.
So what Mike Pence doesn't mention there is
that other countries have already dealt with
Corona virus and they didn't have miracles.
They just did this stuff that our public health
officials recommend.
Mike Pence goes into this very strange rant
about miracles.
And this is a country of miracles and which
maybe we're going to get a miracle.
Other countries have already dealt with the
virus successfully.
Many countries, they didn't have miracles.
They had masks and social distancing and keeping
things closed until it's safe to open them.
Then again, Mike Pence as an accomplishment,
touting veterans choice as an accomplishment
of the Trump administration.
This was an Obama law from 2014.
President Trump kept his word again.
We reformed the V.A. and Veterans Choice is
now available for every veteran in America.
So it used to be just Donald Trump who, when
asked, what are your big accomplishments,
he would say, well, veterans choice is one.
And of course, it's not an accomplishment
of his.
It's a Barack Obama accomplishment.
Now, Mike Pence jumping into that as well.
And then Mike Pence also bragging about opening
up America's schools.
And we're not just opening up America again.
We're opening up America's schools.
The degree to which he says this like a badge
of honor.
Confirms to us that the science doesn't matter.
It's just the optics of saying we're opening
schools.
Despite what the left wants, as I told you
yesterday, thousands, tens of thousands of
cases already at a variety of colleges and
universities that have opened problems in
high schools and elementary schools.
It's an absolute and total disaster.
And then lastly, this is sort of the epitome
of what they are running on.
Mike Pence uses the slogan Make America Great
Again.
But he has to modify it.
Take a look.
Land and with President Donald Trump in the
White House for four more years, and with
God's help, we will make America great again.
Again.
Thank you.
God bless you.
Right.
So if you're still trying to make America
great again after four years, it proves you
didn't do it in the four that you got.
So now they are sort of trying to take advantage
of coronavirus by saying, we did make America
great again.
Then we had coronavirus and we're gonna make
America great again a second time.
The rhetoric yesterday is the type of rhetoric
that I'm worried is going to lead to violence
from Trump ists.
If Trump loses by a small margin, claims it
was rigged.
It is the exact type of rhetoric that will
lead to real world violence.
And we need to talk now about the polling
because some of my fellow leftists are getting
a little bit off the rails
on
this issue.